this summer was when I saw a lot of
growth on my channel because I think it
started in like May of last year when it
first started to like really take off
and like get a lot of subscribers and
actually started making money and it was
just like a fun time and honestly I
started making money and I wasn't even
spending it on me like I was spending it
on other people like buying all this
stuff for the channel and like whatever
but it was just like things are just
like moving and the weather was good and
I was in a shitty apartment but you know
it was a really small operation at that
point like I had a producer and someone
to like help around the apartment